all right hello everyone welcome to
another
design review
for incremental language design for
wolfen language post version 13.
right the first topic here is the
limiting of echo
right so this is something we have
discussed several times and there are a
few possibilities
well certainly nothing is going to be a
string option
i tend to think i guess christopher is
not in this meeting but i tend to think
that
you know
an outer rapper
to a to a big first of all so quiet echo
quiets echoes right
correct
i wonder if quiet echo should take an
argument
that determines
you know
how quickly it quiets it so to speak
because i can see that you know
uh
yeah i wonder if it should have a second
argument
i see it's like our output limiter sorry
they know the message limiter that
limits to three so here we put the
number yes
yes
that's what i'm suggesting yeah i like
that
um
and with an individual echo
what option could we reuse we must have
had a max repeats we've had max
iterations we've had max whatever what
else do we have that's in that
in that family of how many times can you
repeat this
let's see max items max
i don't quite have it do it no i don't
think so
well perhaps we need it actually i think
with your idea of the quiet echo that
could be enough
yeah i mean there's also the the limit
versions of recursion limit output size
limit but it's maybe a little different
of an application
echo limits or
yeah well i mean but that's a question
of um
um
you know it's funny i mean a third of a
century ago we introduced that you know
three messages and it switches off type
thing and that mechanism seems to have
worked quite well over the years
uh
i'm just thinking what the most i mean
do we need fine grain control inside
each echo
so quiet echo of blah comma three
would say make any individual echo only
echo up to three times
right
and the default of quiet echo will be
zero
right in other words don't let it echo
at all
right right
yes
what do you mean by a particular echo
an echo in the code i suppose what do i
mean by a particular echo
so so if expert has four echoes in it it
could echo and
yes that's what i'm saying yes
is that implementable i mean
there are dynamically buildable echoes
which wouldn't be caught this way
right
i think the seventh thing would be just
the maximum number of echoes from
you know the maximum number of times any
echo anywhere in the code could print
yeah i know but i think that's all i
think that's very confusing i think it's
going to lead to people having bugs
i agree that that would be another
possibilities the total max total echoes
that can happen in this
output
uh what if what if um if you just give
an integer it's a global thing but you
can use tags or labels or whatever we
call them an echo
and you could give like
tag one goes to three
but but then you can also just do like
you know all goes to three
no but you could go and i think you want
to go into the individual echoes i mean
we're going to assume the code is right
there that's the normal case i do tend
to agree that this will be the right
thing for the total number of echoes
right
um
but
when echo is signing off it should
produce some message at the end that
says echo is now being quieted
do you understand what i'm saying
no i don't
like like like with messages when you
have to use the third where yes
oh i see yes the rest are suppressed
should be a message or an echo
it should be an echo i assume
we have to design that echo
um
okay so let's go through this so then
umbra prince allowed from echo functions
okay this is this is ian was suggesting
that the same thing for quiet echo
as opposed to the second limiter
right
yep oh yeah okay so we've got
we've got
three things proposed
we've got quiet echo with a global
argument we've got quiet echo referring
to each individual
let's see
you know what we could do
let's imagine that we introduced the max
repeats option
to echo
okay
then we could still do presumably we
could have a max repeats option inside
quiet echo
where quiet echo normally just says how
many total to do
but we can also say
i don't know what the precedence of this
is
max repeats to three
okay which means allow up to three
allow only up to three of each one
and a total of 20.
do you understand what i'm saying
yeah yep
now the only awkwardness is that quiet
echo would then have to have an infinity
you know this case the case where you
just want to limit
everything by three
right would be this case here
right
yeah
that's not that weird
no it's just an annoying thing to have
to type in
look max repeats will do nothing if that
second argument is not present so we
could probably have that default
um
uh
would be
i think that's what we should plan on
right
a total a maximum number there
a
i mean it's a little bit of a shame
with messages we don't have this
mechanism yet
right when you issue a message
you know you have an echo here
but if i issue a message
with the message function right
we could in principle have a max repeats
option there
am i making sense
there's no current way to change that
three
number of how many times the message is
issued
is there are you telling me or i i don't
i don't know that's a question
i don't think there is one no i think
you can switch off
yeah i mean i think this is something
was introduced
you know 34 years ago
and basically has worked fine hasn't
been changed
okay
and this is the only way out of it is
this
okay
now i mean i want to say and i think
ethan on our live stream is commenting
on the same kind of thing
the idea that we have long discussed of
having messages which are off by default
in the code
is something that as we talk about you
know this new effort for bug fixing and
so on and we're redoing a bunch of the
code
um
the um
you know that's something we should look
at again i mean people understand that
idea right
yes
and i think we do have already some
messages that are all by default yeah
like the packing messages
yes
but but i mean the main issue is it is a
you know it's a in fact can we make sure
that it's on the sushma's global project
list
this adding messages that are off by
default could somebody make sure that
addison
yeah i can do that
um because you want to be able to turn
them on like by domain
that's correct that's correct and so
what that means is it's a whole taxonomy
of messages basically
and
there was an effort to do that at some
point in the past and it was really a
flop
and i think we need a better thinking
through of how we do a taxonomy messages
that is you know their sort of concept
tagging of messages so to speak
um
right i mean a lot the common idiom now
is that within a context you have like a
dollar debug
that you can turn on or off or sit to a
level
that controls it
um
but yeah it'd be better to have a
common
tool for everywhere
sorry what were you saying was was the
case
there's it's common that you'll have
something like cloud object backtick
debug level or dollar debug levelers oh
that's horrifying right so which can
which does that exact same thing within
the
backlit of cloud object
but it yeah it's for developers
it'd be good to have one for right i
mean we we need a um
um
okay
so by the way nick is saying on this on
the topic of quiet can we have a way to
turn off quieting of confirmed quiet
oh my gosh what is that for i mean
confirm quiet i don't know how
how does it quieten
you mean turning off the messages which
are being confirmed quieted
is that
is that what we mean no i don't
understand what that that
means doing the behavior of confirmed
quiet but issuing the message
so it throws the failure to the enclosed
but it also issues the message
does this not have a way of assuming
message
that's a question for christopher i
don't know
we could see if christopher is findable
we can ask him
i can try
okay
okay you could get the held message from
the failure and issue that
no but but it just wants to be an option
to confirm quiet presumably that says
don't suppress the message
i'm sure we discussed that and for some
reason we decided not to do that
okay so i'm just
coming back to this so what we're what
we're deciding is quiet echo
should have this ability to allow
through a certain number and a max
repeats on the next repeats option
should be able to go into echo itself
right
that makes sense
yep so what do you prefer
to be an option and not another argument
or a pair of numbers like in capital n
or something like that
because echo needs an option echo
doesn't have any way to do it without an
option does it
or these there are enough optional
arguments to echo we couldn't do it
without an option
i see well i i see a way to support max
repeats and quiet echo but
i i don't know how you would implement
that for
the echo functions themselves
perhaps a tagging mechanism like bob was
saying before a bit like catch and throw
so echo has attack and from up from
outside we say for this tagging allow
10.
probably that's right that's an
implementation issue let's not get into
that let's assume that that that's
doable it seems like it has to be
i mean in worst case something knows
that an echo was issued and it could be
suppressed at the level of the actual
output
um
uh
okay
okay we'll think about that
okay okay echo temporary that will be a
nice thing wow
but the problem is how would we do that
if given that we've got so many
different echo functions
i agree echo temporary will be very nice
um
what's the right way to do it
i mean we understand the idea the idea
is this is a temporary
a temporary cell right
right
um
i mean the other possibility would be to
have a rapper
that says make all echoes in here be
temporary yeah i was thinking about an
analog to like monitor
which is a similar sort of construct
that uses print temporary but has a
single target cell right so instead of
quiet echo we could say temporary echo
effectively
and then all echoes would go to the same
cell id basically
oh if there's if there are five echoes
in there
do they replace each other or are they
no
no they pile up and then they'll
disappear again and then they disappear
at the end
i think that's an interesting global
construct and it might be more useful
than having
them having an individual echo temporary
because if you have an individual echo
temporary i mean arguably we should do
the same thing with prince
right if we're doing this for echoes we
should do it for prince also
well i think people shouldn't use print
well
that's not for you to decide
well
print
like i don't think there's a cell print
temporary
no
self contemporary will be it okay so
wait a minute so print the template
temporary but there is no cell print
temporary
that probably should be
okay but this idea is
i mean this is kind of an interesting
idea because it could be done partially
in parts of the code right
so if you have this wrapper you have one
piece of code it accumulates a bunch of
print out and then shunk
it disappears very similar to our how
our progress monitoring system works
am i making sense
did you understand what i'm saying yes
does anybody know who here is is
involved with the progress monitoring
system because that's going to be
similar to this and we want it to work
the same way
i think that's italian julia
okay
so
we probably should have a review of that
we should have an idea of how we're
going to do this
and then we should have a review of that
to make sure it's consistent
does that make sense
yep i got that
okay
um
i don't know what the right names for
these are i mean echo temporary might be
useful on its own but we need this
rapper
okay so quiet echo
and by the way notice that with quite
echo as a wrapper it means that in a
section of the code you can say up to
this number in this section of the code
and up to some number in another section
of the code
right
uh
okay well anyway okay nobody's saying
anything here so i'm we're gonna move on
i mean we're
i mean we need a wrapper like this what
should it be called
what do you think of echo monitored
and the proposals for other ways that
you might want to uh
monitor the echoes
like we talked about replacing egypt
though but also letting them pile up
okay first in first out et
cetera if it's going to work on print
and cell print it could be something
like temporary print block
no i like this idea of the replacement
i mean that could be done in evaluate
with progress
evaluate with progress is the thing for
the monitoring system
right right julius thing which
what's that
but it isn't finished yet right it isn't
finished right
why is this why
is that can we report this again again
and again again why is that showing up
on the auto complete
okay alison please report that again yep
just screenshot it
okay
so
ethan says why not overload quiet
let's look at quiet
i don't think it's quite going to have
the right functionality but
you know this idea of quiet echo with a
number here probably should be extended
to quiet
am i making sense and this was the idea
for bank switching of messages
am i making sense
so that that could be something i've
wanted sometimes is that in the same way
that we limit to three each message
there could be a total limit to the
number of
total messages admit it yeah right
that's so that's exactly what we would
do with this
this would be saying quiet by default is
a zero there
and with a different number would be
you know
but quite effectively has an infinity
right now because it lets
many messages to be printed
oh no no sorry no no no no
yes that's right it
it's infinity with a max repeats of
like three
what are you talking about that's the
default for everything
but quiet if you say quiet it is no
messages get printed oh
so it's the exact same thing as quiet
echo
right it's the exact same thing add an
argument to quiet the same way we're
talking about adding an argument to
quiet echo
now the issue is
what about
what what quiet has to do with messages
it does not have to do with prints
right i mean you understand what i'm
saying i think prints are out of the
picture i think prints are their own
thing if you if you're doing print you
get what you get
you know echo is the thing that is
intended to be the modern
form of that
that um
you know
is uh for doing intermediate stuff in
code
okay
all right so what i think we should do
i like the idea of the second argument
to quiet but i still think
okay
um
i like the idea of being able to do that
replacement type thing
um
of and i don't know whether that's
something that should be in quiet echo
the ability to do the replacement
do you understand what i'm saying
no right as opposed to letting them just
pile up and disappear oh right right
well no i see quiet echo prevents them
appearing in the first place
so the next issue is appear and then
disappear
right sorry i was thinking about
echo right so then that will be
temporary echo
right
um
oh yeah i think we need to
to discuss temporary echo we need to
discuss evaluate with progress because
they're going to be very similar so
let's get that back on the agenda for
that
okay
i got it yep christopher's here by the
way also
okay
christopher the question was raised
about confirm quiet and why confirm
quiet
cannot give
cannot actually generate its message
uh what do you mean by generates message
i mean so
just for reference the behavior of
confirmed quiet just changed i think
with 13.0 so that it it it it uh it has
the correct behavior with interacting
with quiets which was the main thing we
talked about before which is why it was
listed as experimental
so wait a second so what does that mean
does that mean if you do confirm quiet
does confirm quiet here if i do this
okay it doesn't
produce that message it doesn't actually
say one over zero
right it suppresses the messages that it
that it catches
yes but why
because if the whole point is that
you're basically handling the error then
you don't want to print a bunch of
messages anyway
i see but the question that's being
asked is what if you did want that
message printed
um then i think the easiest way to do it
is you can um
the second argument to be of enclose
yeah you can you can print it out again
actually that was that was another point
there was a bug actually i should
probably reply to this bug because i
think it was also fixed in this 13
change which is if you look inside the
failure object for uh that confirmed
quiet generates it now includes a held
version of the call to message so you
just have to release hold that and it
will print the message
okay so if i look at this thing here
there we go hold message call
right
so that also wasn't there before which i
think maybe made it so that there was a
little bit of information that was
missing in order to reproduce the
message but now now everything should be
there
okay
um
okay question why is it not is it
thought useful enough that there should
be an option to confirm quiet to
actually generate the message in real
time
um
well
that's an interesting question i mean
the first thing is that options are
generally a little bit difficult for all
the confirmed functions
because they sort of
like confirm quiet for example can take
up two i forget it's like three or four
uh four arguments right and and and and
a lot of the arguments are like in
particular the third and fourth
arguments can have can be any expression
right because one of them is the
information the other is a tag
so it's sort of options are a bit
difficult
um
i guess in principle there could be one
but i
yeah
that would be my concern and also of
course you can't just write automatic
and all those in all those fields like
you can put null for information but the
moment you put a tag the behavior of
confirmed quiet is different from if
there's no tag
i mean maybe we could have something
like for some special tag like you know
none or something like that it will
behave as though you didn't provide any
tag at all but i mean it's the same
problem with throw and catch where
if you the minute you give throw a tag
it's a totally different animal
well it doesn't seem like the most
important issue to be able to
to do this now
uh i think it's worthwhile being able to
do but the way to do it i think is just
by handling it in the second argument
and close i mean maybe there could be an
easier
you know uh and an easier function for
doing that but i don't know exactly what
it would look like
i actually will
maybe this is a little off topic for
this meeting but there was another thing
which which i actually added to enclose
but which is not documented yet partly
because it doesn't have a good enough
name
and that is basically
there are certain um
so the second argument of enclosed in
general is a function which takes the
failure object and processes it and does
whatever it wants to do
but um you can also give it a string and
it will use that string to sort of um
basically uh query a property as the
third usage there queer query or
property from the failure object um
but so uh
in 13 there's now also another string
i'm trying to remember exactly what it's
called it's called like propagated
failure or inherited failure or
something like that which basically
makes it so that
um because basically you can get
situations where you called confirm and
confirm wraps this other failure in
another layer of failure object and so
this special string basically makes it
so that it will you know
it just runs a function that you know
processes it to
to remove any of those outer nestings of
failure so you just get the original
error which is sort of very common
operation you want to do so it might
make sense i mean if if that actually
gets documented and stuff like that i
don't again i don't know what the right
name would be for it then it might make
sense to have other kind of named
processing pipelines like you know oh if
it was a confirm if it was a failure
from a confirmed quiet then throw the
message again if that makes sense right
but what you're saying is
that thing which is right now documented
to merely take the failure object and
sub value into it with property
you're proposing that that property be
able to do something more fancy than
that is that correct
yeah basically and i mean there's some
ways of doing that which might work by
modifying failure there are some ways of
modifying failure in simple not totally
crazy ways that might mean that
that enclosed can still technically just
you know
query into failure but i think it's it's
probably cleaner if if uh
and then in particular you might end up
with a list of
stringed properties so to speak as the
second argument have been closed if you
want to both generate the message and
propagate things and blah blah blah you
could end up with a string with a with a
list of strings there yes
well but
maybe yes i mean i that that could be
useful but the thing is for example the
the one that that exists right now for
propagating failures i mean all that
does is it changes the return behavior
of enclosed
right so so if you imagine if you had
multiple things that just change what
doesn't close return
then it's a little bit unclear which
which one you use i mean maybe you just
use the last one in the list
um
i understand i understand so what it has
to define that there's two possibilities
number one enclosed can have side
effects
uh
well a number there is one
side effects yeah yeah right
and then maybe maybe it's just a matter
of you have a list and
it will run all of them whether they
produce side effects or not or whatever
and it returns whatever
whatever is determined by the last one
yeah
but the thing that you're saying is
that you need something where it is a
propagation
of um
um
let's see is some
uh
where
okay where it propagates
let's see what you're saying is the
failure object wants to cascade upwards
so that is very similar to an old thing
in the event handler
which has a similar kind of upward
propagation issue
right because in an event handler
there's the question of do you propagate
right
i i think so yeah but this is a little
bit different because basically the
issue here is not whether it propagates
it the issue is is sort of a very
specific
question about the behavior of confirm
like that
the norm will confirm
so basically the point is is that this
you know standard confirm one of its
main usages is for propagating existing
failures so that is
you know you call some function it
produces a failure or it might produce a
failure you wrap it in confirm so that
you know if it produces a failure you're
going to stop everything and go to the
enclosed etc
so
the point is though is that
in
confirm
uh
confirm will
confirm will basically wrap the failure
that it gets in another level of failure
which is this confirmation fail which
has a bunch of metadata about where did
it fail what were the circumstances
which it failed etc and you know stuff
like that
and so the point is is that by default
that confirmation failed failure is the
thing that gets to the top level but
often that's not what you want
because all you really care about is
just that inner failure that triggered
the confirmation you don't care about
the actual you know the little
confirmation failed wrapper around it
um
so
that's the point of that but so there's
this sort of very simple function that
you know
that like i've written several times i
talked to some other people who had also
written this a few times that's
basically like oh you check you know
that the
the failure object has a certain
structure and that it comes from a
certain place and so on and if those are
all met it's basically the simplest case
then you unwrap it and just produce the
the inner failure
if that makes sense okay it's easier to
show if i had an example but well maybe
maybe we should pick this up at a
different time but yeah i'm not sure
this is relevant for this meeting but
right but so
okay so i think the answer here go ahead
uh i was going to point out that in
relation to failure propagation uh it
might also be good to look at failure
action
the option failure action of query
because it has to handle with a similar
situation
right this is about whether it stops
immediately versus it it continues yeah
okay
yeah this does seem relevant
and arguably this should be somehow
merged with the whole confirmed business
like how on earth does this play with
with confirming close
i mean
it depends on which option you pick i
mean like like for example you know if
like at some level any function that
returns a failure object should play
fairly nicely
so i mean if you call if you call this
and
you use i think it's the default value
for failure action where where a query
or data set will like return some
failure objects then that will
that will work just fine
i mean maybe there could be some special
ones that
sort of uh
you know where acts confirm function but
i'm not sure how useful that is
yeah
okay
let me let me i think we should try and
we're going to run out of time here so
so
um for the for another time let's talk
about this cascading failures business
um
maybe we should take a quick look at
this
what is this
okay so you can just evaluate this code
and look at the examples it's just um
um some thoughts after our meetings uh
this week so on a race so this is
something i will
present more carefully next week but for
example this this is an object that
tries to combine lists and associations
and then handle both simultaneously in
the way we have been discussing without
repeating keys etc
okay and to what extent is it now this
transducing kind of idea where it is
basically you know where it's a
templating wrapping thing is that what
this is or is this not that
yes this this is a very small prototype
of the idea but just wanted to get your
first feelings about it and uh
and yes so this will be combined
eventually with more powerful
functionality i see bob actually
mentioning here
who could actually
use his voice to say something but um
you were in a good conversation with
christopher i didn't want to
interrupt all right okay
but um mentioning capture echoes
i don't know i don't know what would
capture mean
it means they're not
put into new cells in the notebook
they're just shown in the progress bar
what do you mean by oh i see oh i see
that's an interesting that's an
interesting option as well right using
the upcoming progress thing that we're
doing as the mechanism for
this replacement so throwing basically
what you're saying is
do you want to copy that onto the screen
yeah yeah yeah um does it work
no
um
and is the idea that if you call it
twice the second call will replace the
first one the second echo within expert
would replace the first one
okay yeah that would be super i mean so
basically the idea is it's just like a
you call this to say this is what i'm
doing right now and then in a nice
progress window you know it'll have a
little section that's just like this is
what i'm doing that would be super nice
yes i agree
i agree i mean i think this is in the
category
of
you know this whole idea of notifiers
that don't you know non-journaling
notifiers so to speak
notifiers that which is not something
we've traditionally you know notebooks
are traditionally something where it
stores the history
but this is an example of something
where you want
you know a thing that is writing and
overwriting so to speak it's a different
model for what's going on and i think a
general model that just like print
temporary
you know that there should be some
mechanism where echo print et cetera et
cetera et cetera can target
a replaceable region which is
essentially what this is what you're
saying here right right i mean the
progress stuff that's going in at some
point
is already that for a whole bunch of
things it could be that right because
right but i mean i had always thought
that send message which right now can do
things like send you a text message
should also be able to send a message to
some notifier on the screen which would
have something like this property oh
yeah
right so okay
maybe one question though is is whether
or not i mean i i would think this
should be its own echo
star function because i mean if nothing
else
i mean this is one question is whether
you'd ever want to have normal echoes
alongside this and it seems like you
might at least
the problem is that we also have echo
evaluating things like this
right you would double the number of
functions right right so what we have
been discussing earlier is a wrapper
called temporary echo or something that
is a wrapper around a block of code that
causes like a print temporary except not
like a print temporary because it's an
outside in rather than inside out right
type operation
alternatively you could have an option
in all the echo functions that's
you know
temporary
i don't know that something like
temporary goes to dollar temporary
which by default is
false
right by the way so i mean well one of
the issues that we're doing like this is
i mean it seems like there could be
scoping problems i mean like for example
if you're calling map and the the
function that you're mapping with
you know if it has an echo in it i don't
know i don't i'm not sure if you want
that to be captured
um
but yeah
well from the outside i think you say
from the outside if you wanted look both
things are useful saying from the inside
and saying from the outside because you
might have a thing where you've got a
bunch of echoes in there and there's a
huge number of echoes in this piece of
code
but you just want to see them you know
because then i would leave echoes in my
code a lot more if it was a temporary
thing right as opposed just you put them
in you edit them out which is why
i mean like there are some functions
like okay for example map where
there's the the operation of map itself
and then there's the operation of the
function they're using to map with
right so you can imagine that if i was
implementing math or some map like
function
that i would i would implement all these
sort of captured echoes where it gives
all this nice information about what
it's doing right now
but then if separately you put echoes in
your
f your function that's being mapped
it will interfere with that yeah
in other words it would have it would
have an encapsulation inside there in
the same thing that that's what in the
case of confirm was fixed with the
lexical
version of confirm right
sure yeah i mean you can either have a
lexical thing or you can have some sort
of you know like what's it called the
stack inhibit or whatever i mean neither
of these are particularly pretty
right okay for a different time um by
the way ethan is commenting
that event handler
should have pinch zoom drag drop pan etc
in event handler that's a comment for
the front end team
and should be passed on to them addison
that's for you yep just merge it down
okay very quick look at this array
association so
uh
jose to what extent is it the case that
this is in fact like that kind of
framing system that we discussed before
yeah so the the data frame that has been
discussed other times is very focused on
columns and matrices i want to have
something that is of any depth
sure
and and that handles rugged cases etc so
here so for at the very end you see a
more interesting example i've started
with probably two trivial things here
and i will have a better thing for next
week's
arrays for example
so this case for example at the end we
do have an array of random integers and
then lots of headers
so here we see how by writing it in this
case we gain like 22 times space
and then we can easily expose it because
we are just acting on the arrays of
numbers rather than the keys the keys
are stored only once sure
and and so this is but then but the the
whole point is that when you access this
from the outside i can access it by keys
for example exactly yes exactly yes and
keys and numbers this combines if if one
of these lists of headers is a three
rather than a list of three objects then
that behaves exactly as a list
and so it this object handles
simultaneously lists and associations in
a common way
as it inner
peace let me just understand what is the
basic semantics here
yes so the these examples are showing
that
uh you can have any part spec
and internally it's just the data comma
uh
what i call headers which is a list of
either a number
or a list of keys
these cases are associated sorry lists
so okay okay but can they be ragged
uh it will be yes
i'm working with rob to have his new
rugged structures to be able to be
handled here and this this will work
with that
so the the
yeah so we want to handle simultaneously
these three axes oh i see the thing
that's super confusing to me is what i
see is the output here which is really
not what i should see probably exactly
exactly yeah i haven't prepared okay
okay okay but that object because it has
a list of keys it behaves like an
association i i get it again this makes
perfect sense this is what we've
discussed and this makes perfect sense
to me exactly so at the end of your
screen right now you have this mixed
case in which you have three comma a b
so yeah i guess
yeah i get it it's a list of
associations exactly
yeah this is this is exactly how it
should work
yeah
um
and this here is an association of
associations with keys one two three
right exactly yeah you see the normal
form
and so you can access 2b
this is so the length of the the
the list in this the headers is the
equal to the depth is that basically it
yeah
the position is the depth the length is
the dimension
right okay no then the length of the sub
elements what customer was asking the
length the total length of the whole
list of headers is equal to the depth of
the whole expression exactly yeah right
and i mean i don't know quite what
happens with raggedness but but um i
mean presumably it takes these things
you know if you give a whole bunch of
headers and there aren't enough elements
in the raw data list it will just take
the head as it can
right so
it's something we have a uh some sort of
sparse representation of the ruggedness
in the first argument some efficient
representation and that it is also doing
the separation of the data and the
dimensions drag the dimensions and so
the data can still be packed for example
so
rob is working on that you will see that
in in one of the features array meetings
okay that's exciting
okay this is basically what we had
discussed previously of um this is nice
i mean and then
uh
i mean sort of the beginnings of a more
chunkable
um
you know once we have this kind of
framing
the inner creature of data here could
certainly start to be something that
isn't even local
right exactly so whatever we put in the
first argument is a separate
implementation thing so here we are
discussing the
the object that the users will interact
with with proper names and proper type
settings etc
so by the way what about um
uh
what about if if the elements at the
bottom
if they're different types like if one
of them is a string and some of them are
are integers or something like that
does the
i i guess
maybe this just doesn't so i guess the
question was gonna be does the list part
uh have some way of storing that so it's
packed but i guess that's if you use you
know rob's
you know some some compiler data
structure then you can pack it is that
sort of the theory of it
or like it doesn't laid out so that
existing packed arrays will
be sort of optimized right
uh well not the existing ones he's
working on a new object
that is able to handle packetness and
ruggedness at the same time so it's
better if he explains that in in a
future meeting okay yeah but i guess
it's more than just raggedness though
right because it's also you know it's
that you'll have you know if
if the whole thing is a big list of
associations and one sort of column is
this
type string and one column is type
integer then
right you know yeah the types is a bit
like what happens in quantity array you
have to put the types at the very bottom
it's the very bottom the columns at the
very bottom or the keys at the very
bottom that need to be tagged
and so it's this idea of deep threading
that we have discussed other times that
is used in quantity array
okay
yeah so the units go in pairs for
example and so that means at the very
bottom level of the quantity array you
worry about meters and seconds
right you just store meters and i mean
obviously the the remaining thing is the
missings business
but this is nice i mean this is kind of
what we were discussing a couple of days
ago
and um already a partial implementation
this is great yeah i'm hoping to have
something better for next week
sounds good all right we should wrap up
here um
and uh
uh
i know we've got many things to discuss
yeah lots of things to discuss
for the future
but um
not for right now
all right anything else we need to cover
for sure here
nope okay
thanks to everybody here thanks to folks
on the live stream and uh see you all
soon